Buon Giorno a few nights ago Italy's
former Deputy Prime Minister paid a
visit to an Italian Tunisian family home
asking to be let in the premise he said
to find out if the family's youngest son
was a drug dealer
but the humiliation of a family targeted
over a rumor was live-streamed of a
Mateo salvini social media page without
any evidence to support the allegation
it is a tactic that has suited the
leaked party leaders quest to clickbait
his weight of popularity if there was
ever a time where the league could
dominate Italy it would be now even some
familiar faces such as former Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi also lending
his support historically emilia-romagna
has always been left-wing it was a base
for the resistance during fascist Italy
and it's proud of that tradition but
right-wing parties have been trying to
break that emilia romagna
long live freedom democracy strong on
slogans but little offered in the way of
detail yet against the odds the league
have powered through in the opinion
polls putting them just behind for
center-left candy
but it has not gone unchallenged pushing
back has been the phenomenon of the
so-called sardine movement left-wing
activists fearful of a far-right
takeover have been loudly voicing their
opposition at the direction Italy is
taking for the sardine movement the rise
of salvini and his politics ashes in a
warning from the past but is important
that we party in sovereignties this type
of populism has the same roots as
fascism we were all resigned to the
narrative because there wasn't an
alternative but from our first
demonstration in Bologna we managed to
cause a reaction all over Italy the
sardine activists hope that they can
usher in a new wave of politics that
focuses on dealing with people's
grievances rather than using populist
tactics if they can take on the might of
a hard right party that has seen its
support swell over the past two years
could easily see its power consolidated
across the country so nigahiga al
Jazeera Bologna Italy